Trascrizione: Nicoletta Pedrana
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Siete pronti per il vostro
"Momento Morandi"?
E non mi riferisco alla presenza
al Festival di Sanremo,
e non penso alle vostre
performance canore sotto la doccia,
o ai vostri video su Tik Tok.
Penso a un momento diverso,
al momento in cui sarete proiettati
sul palcoscenico della crisi.
Il momento in cui la terra
sotto i vostri piedi cederà,
il momento in cui il mondo
vi crollerà addosso.
Il momento in cui qualcuno
vi metterà controvoglia nella lavatrice,
e schiaccierà il bottone della centrifuga.
E quando uscirete, avrete perso
tutti i vostri punti di riferimento.
Questo è un "Momento Morandi".
I momenti Morandi
non toccano solo le imprese;
toccano tutti noi,
nella nostra vita quotidiana.
La cattiva notizia è proprio questa.
Un amico malato, una morte in famiglia,
la morte di un figlio.
E anche le imprese:
magari un collaboratore disonesto,
un mercato che improvvisamente scompare.
E anche le istituzioni:
le crisi toccano tutti.
Quando parliamo di questi argomenti,
di solito ci sono delle reazioni
che tutti noi immediatamente
abbiamo, istintivamente.
E allora facciamo un piccolo test insieme:
non vi vedo molto bene,
ma proviamo a farlo lo stesso.
E mentre vi parlavo di queste cose,
che non sono cose evidentemente gradevoli,
sicuramente vi saranno passati
dei pensieri per la testa
e forse qualcuno avrà, anche,
commesso qualche gesto.
Non so quanti tra voi,
potrete alzare le mani,
quanti tra voi hanno pensato
o hanno, sotto la sedia,
fatto questo gesto.
Pochi.
Allora, forse, altri avranno fatto questo.
(Risate)
Un pochettino meno elegante,
un pochettino più di genere,
due gesti che un nostro ex primo ministro
utilizzava abbastanza frequentemente.
E poi, forse, vedo che -
se questa non è la vostra linea culturale,
allora forse voi rientrate
in questa categoria:
la categoria di chi si tiene in tasca,
magari sullo specchietto
retrovisore dell'auto,
un cornetto.
Sarete forse sorpresi di sapere
che in questi tre atteggiamenti
ce n'è uno che è particolarmente virtuoso.
E non so se qualcuno
vuole provare a indovinare:
se no, ve lo dico io.
L'atteggiamento virtuoso è il terzo.
Perché è un atteggiamento virtuoso?
Perché se voi avete deciso
di andare dal tabaccaio, o su Amazon,
e spendere due euro
per comprarvi un cornetto portafortuna,
vuol dire che vi siete posti un problema,
vi siete posti una domanda.
Quando mi si chiede:
"Come ci si prepara
alla gestione di crisi?"
dico sempre che il punto di partenza
è quello di farsi un film,
di farsi un film in testa.
E questo film non è una commedia:
questo film, ahimè, è un film dell'orrore.
Consapevoli che la realtà sarà
molto superiore alla vostra immaginazione.
Il punto di partenza di questo film
è una domanda, ed è una domanda sola.
What If?
Che cosa succede se...?
Che cosa faccio se..?
È una domanda molto semplice,
ce la possiamo fare quotidianamente.
Io ho iniziato a farmela:
ho iniziato a pensare,
quando mi sono sposato -
non subito, evidentemente,
ma un pochettino più in là -
che cosa avrei fatto
se fosse successo qualcosa
a mia moglie o a mia figlia,
le due persone in assoluto
più importanti per me.
E questo è un pensiero
molto difficile da gestire:
non c'è una risposta, non c'è un film
che puoi proiettare davanti a questo.
E allora, un giorno
ho smesso di chiedermi
che cosa avrei fatto io,
e ho iniziato a chiedermi
che cosa avrebbero fatto loro.
Ho iniziato a pensare come sarebbero state
le ore, i giorni,
le settimane, i mesi dopo.
E allora mi sono detto:
c'è qualcosa che posso fare
per aiutare, Dio non voglia,
in una situazione così drammatica
e tremenda e dolorosa?
Ho preso una penna,
ho preso un foglio di carta
e ho scritto a mia moglie un messaggio.
L'ho chiuso, l'ho messo in un cassetto,
e lei sa perfettamente dov'è quella busta.
In quella busta, logicamente,
ci sono delle parole di amore,
ci sono le parole che un marito
scambia con una moglie.
E poi ci sono delle altre cose:
ci sono delle istruzioni.
Chi è l'avvocato, chi è il commercialista,
dove sono i conti in banca,
chi è l'assicuratore.
Perché spesso ci dimentichiamo
che nei "Momenti Morandi"
perdiamo tutti i punti di riferimento.
Allora ho pensato che questo
poteva essere un piccolo aiuto,
un piccolo contributo per aiutarla -
ripeto, spero di no;
ma nella vita non si può mai sapere -
a superare quel momento.
Perché ho iniziato ad occuparmi
di questa tematica?
Ho iniziato a pormi
la domanda del "What If"
non subito, un pochettino più avanti.
Ma il giorno preciso
è l'otto ottobre del 2001.
È incredibile come -
non so se qualcuno di voi
ha avuto l'esperienza
di vivere un momento
veramente difficile della propria vita,
come -
in quei momenti, veramente,
non sai dove guardare.
Quel giorno, l'otto ottobre 2001,
me lo ricordo come fosse ieri.
Ma non mi ricordo tutto il giorno,
e non mi ricordo i giorni successivi.
Quello che è incredibile
è che in questi momenti
ti restano in mente delle Polaroid.
Degli istanti, delle sensazioni.
E allora, oggi ho pensato
che poteva essere utile
condividere con voi
quello che io ho vissuto quel giorno.
L'otto ottobre del 2001
mi sono alzato alle sei del mattino,
come facevo oramai da tre anni,
da quando mio papà se ne era andato.
E mi ero buttato nel lavoro.
E uscii di casa, come facevo ogni mattina,
e attraversai la strada
per andare a prendere
il cappuccino e il cornetto al bar.
E quel giorno c'era una nebbia
come quelle che conosciamo qui,
dalle nostre parti,
che tagliavi con un coltello:
non si vedeva da un lato
all'altro della strada.
E poi, alle undici e mezza,
ero seduto alla mia scrivania in ufficio.
Squilla il telefono, ricevo una chiamata
dalle linee aeree scandinave, dalla Sas,
che mi chiede se posso,
urgentemente, andare a Linate.
E allora raccolgo il computer,
chiedo a un paio di colleghi di seguirmi,
saliamo in macchina e ci dirigiamo
verso l'aeroporto di Linate.
La prima Polaroid è viale Forlanini:
un viale Forlanini completamente deserto.
Non c'è traffico, non c'è nessuno.
Arriviamo davanti all'ingresso
dell'aeroporto di Linate,
e c'è una pattuglia
dei carabinieri di traverso,
che blocca la strada.
Ci qualifichiamo, e arriviamo
davanti all'aerostazione.
Scendo dall'auto, alzo gli occhi,
guardo il cielo -
un cielo blu, profondo,
con un sole forte -
e penso alla mattina.
Penso a quella nebbia
che si tagliava col coltello:
tutto d'un tratto,
una giornata meravigliosa.
Mi guardo intorno, non si muove niente.
Non so se vi ricordate
un telefilm di fantascienza,
che si chiamava UFO,
dove c'era un comandante,
comandante Stracker.
E c'è un episodio di questo film,
dove lui è in movimento
e tutte le persone,
e tutte le cose intorno a lui
sono assolutamente immobili.
Questa era la scena alla quale
io ho assistito arrivando a Linate:
una scena assolutamente surreale.
Un aeroporto deserto e silenzioso.
E poi, gli odori.
Gli odori - è incredibile, fateci caso -
ti restano impressi nella mente,
e non vanno più via.
L'odore del kerosene nell'aria;
l'odore di bruciato;
l'odore di schiumogeni
dei Vigili del Fuoco.
Una sensazione incredibile,
che mi porterò dietro tutta la vita.
Entrando nell'aerostazione,
pensavo:
quante volte sono entrato
in questo aeroporto,
quante volte ho preso questi aerei.
La vita dell'aeroporto, viva;
gli annunci degli imbarchi; i check-in;
le persone che comprano i giornali;
chi beve il cappuccino, il caffè,
l'aperitivo, il pranzo.
Sono luoghi di vita.
E questo era un aeroporto deserto.
Mi avvio verso gli ascensori
per salire al piano ammezzato,
dove c'erano gli uffici
delle compagnie aeree.
E tutto d'un tratto, così,
con la coda dell'occhio,
vedo verso destra
un corridoio male illuminato.
E vedo delle ombre
che si muovono in questo corridoio.
Ma purtroppo, non sono delle ombre.
Sono i familiari.
Alcuni dei familiari
delle 118 vittime di Linate,
che vagano in questo aeroporto senza meta,
alla ricerca dei loro cari.
Paola Rota aveva 20 anni.
I suoi genitori erano su quell'aereo.
E c'era anche il fratellino.
Paola mi chiamò due anni dopo.
Mi chiamò in ufficio, e mi disse:
"Vorrei venire a incontrarla".
"Più che volentieri", risposi.
Arrivò in ufficio,
si sedette davanti a me,
mi guardò negli occhi e mi disse:
"Io sto preparando la tesi
sull'incidente di Linate.
Sono venuta per raccogliere
delle informazioni".
Tirammo fuori i faldoni,
le spiegai tutto il lavoro
che noi, a supporto
della compagnia aerea, avevamo svolto,
e non potei non restare impressionato
dalla forza di questa ragazza
che dopo quella tragedia
aveva deciso di fare la tesi
su quell'incidente.
Forse un modo per superare il lutto.
Paola non c'è più.
Dieci anni più tardi,
Paola si è tolta la vita.
Penso e ripenso
a quel corridoio di Linate,
a quel silenzio.
E mi chiedo: perché quel silenzio
non è stato riempito di comunicazione?
Perché nessuno si è preoccupato
di spendere delle parole
di accoglienza, di affetto, di vicinanza?
E la comunicazione non è solo parole.
La comunicazione è anche fatta di gesti:
un abbraccio, una stretta di mano,
una carezza, una lacrima.
A Linate, purtroppo, quel giorno
non ci fu nulla di tutto questo.
Perché?
Me lo sono chiesto,
per tanti anni mi sono chiesto
perché quel silenzio
in quel corridoio di Linate.
Perché nessuno ad accogliere
quelle persone in sofferenza?
Mi sono dato due risposte.
La prima è che nessuno
si era fatto quella domanda:
What If?
Cosa facciamo, se c'è un incidente aereo?
Come ci organizziamo?
Nessuno, al di fuori
della compagnia aerea,
si era posto quella domanda.
E il secondo motivo è la paura.
È la paura di confrontarsi
con le proprie responsabilità,
è la paura di confrontarsi
con il dolore degli altri.
Noi, nei momenti difficili di crisi,
abbiamo una straordinaria risorsa,
che sono le nostre emozioni.
Ma non sono gli emoticon dei telefonini,
non sono i messaggini che mandiamo:
sono le emozioni che sentiamo
nel cuore e nella testa.
Sono le emozioni che dobbiamo
utilizzare, e modulare.
Modulare la paura,
e far emergere le altre emozioni.
Metterci nei panni degli altri,
usare la massima espressione
della nostra intelligenza:
l'empatia,
entrare in relazione con gli altri.
Non con i messaggini:
con le parole e con i gesti.
Siete pronti per il vostro
"Momento Morandi"?
Non credo che si possa essere pronti,
però ci si può preparare.
E allora ricordatevi,
quando quel momento verrà -
perché verrà: non è una questione di se,
è una questione di quando -
ricordatevi di usare le vostre emozioni.
Ricordatevi, se il momento è vostro,
di usare le parole e i gesti
per chiedere aiuto.
E non abbiate paura, se il momento
è di qualcuno che vi è vicino,
o anche di qualcuno che non conoscete,
di fare il passo.
Le emozioni sono
una straordinaria risorsa:
Non comprimetele, non nascondetele:
usatele.
E invece di chiudervi nel silenzio
di quel corridoio di Linate, apritevi.
Apritevi alla comunicazione,
perché la comunicazione,
nei momenti di difficoltà della vita,
è quella che vi può aiutare.
(Applausi)